john starts off this hour in toronto hey
john what's up in your world
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help
uh so i'm 21 years old just graduated
from school
congratulations what's your degree in uh
paramedicine
good what are you gonna be making uh 40
bucks an hour
good good for you yeah so i have
thank you i have about 21 000 in loans
about seven thousand dollars in my
savings
and the interest on the loans only about
fifteen dollars a month
so i'm kind of wondering should i be
dumping ninety percent of my paycheck
into paying off my student loans or kind
of
putting half on student loans and hops
in the savings account kind of thing
and the savings account pays nothing
um it's just like a student savings
account right now so it's nothing i have
to set up something better
yeah nothing yeah and so we're gonna not
pay off the student loans because they
don't charge a lot and we're gonna save
money and make nothing
yeah that's pretty much what i'm doing
right now
yeah so when you're 31 uh
i think you're going to be really glad
that i kicked your butt and told you to
pay off your student loans
immediately don't screw around with
these things
and here's the thing you're correct
mathematically
and that the interest is not that high
but there's another interest that you're
paying and it's the weight
of them hanging around your neck that
makes you even question the situation
you can feel the weight across the tops
of your shoulders and runs down your
back
and occasionally it manifests itself in
a headache yeah
you have a physical reaction to debt uh
you have an
emotional reaction to debt you have a
spiritual reaction to debt that has
nothing to do with mathematics
but it does affect your life and the
quality of your life and you'll know
that i'm right about this
when you're free of it and you feel
light
and airy and wow i had no idea
this feels so nice the ritual's over the
poor
and the borrower is slave
to the lender when a slave is set free
they are free indeed so set yourself
free young man
as fast as you possibly can that's what
i would do